how was your meeting with President  Trump it was terrific did you guys talk  at all about tax policy what  specifically on tax policy are you  hoping we we did talk about tax policy  we talked about nothing specific at this  point but just the overall need to  reduce the tax burden and especially for  aviation the travel ban come up at all  it did not  and what about subsidizing I know there  was some talk about subsidizing with  Qatar and frustration with that did that  come up conversation was limited to  primarily infrastructure investment but  we talked a little bit as I said about  tax reform and regulatory reform but  nothing very specific it was more about  how we might get organized to work  together with the administration he gave  Jerry Cohen the assignment to work with  the airlines to come up with a punch  list of actionable item